then along comes this young guy to
Oakland I'm going what Ryan Coogler Ryan
Coogler there's a short sightedness that
comes with playing with playing foreign
sports
I don't know if College has a Dean of
discipline with my high school dislike
like Dean a discipline at the school and
his hiring and I'm going for this world
we're meeting I was shocked house was
angered I was a frustrated scared
there's nothing like seeing it seeing a
great movie and being a filmmaker so
because it's inspiring he's an American
film director and screenwriter his first
feature film Fruitvale station won two
awards at the 2013 Sundance Film
Festival he also wrote and directed the
seventh film in the rocky saga Creed
he's ryan coogler and here is my take on
his top ten rules of success rule number
one is my personal favorite and I'm
really curious if your groats which one
you guys like the best also as Ryan is
talking if we set something that's
really impactful to you that really
means a lot to you please leave it in
the comments below and put quotes around
it so other people can be inspired as
well enjoy
[Music]
you
the last Rocky movie before Creed the
final scene was it your way of saying
goodbye to the character goodbye to that
yeah goodbye to everything combines the
best chapters of my life in these
professional life it really was then
along comes this young guy to Oakland I
want what Ryan Coogler Ryan Coogler when
director Ryan Coogler first met with
Stallone he was untested as a feature
filmmaker but he had an intensely
personal idea for reviving the rocky
franchise googlers father had fallen
gravely ill a few years earlier with
Ryan by his side there was only one
thing the elder Kugler wanted to watch
the father's a very soulful powerful man
and now he's being reduced to a shell of
his former self but oddly he watches
rocky again in again and he can't his
son who loves his father sitting right
beside him he's watching his father
disintegrate before his very eyes the
traumatic impact was so imprinted on
this young man that he never got over it
so he comes to me because hey look at
this great idea lemon you know revived
rocky I go how and when he told me
stories this is insane
wrong you're a young kid you haven't
done anything yet but I appreciate the
thought because okay see you around
and because that he does a masterpiece
Fruitvale station wins the Cannes Film
Festival every studio wants and what's
he want to do Creed then went now either
this guy here is just trying my patience
or he's reminds me of a guy I used to
know I was gonna say that was you that
40 years ago yeah it was absolutely then
I realized this is not a movie for him
for his father this is all about a love
letter to his father
now if you've really dug down deep and
ask a real rocky fan why he likes the
movies it's usually because they watched
it with someone that they love was so
great about them is they're so personal
to people no people just associate him
with their family
I know the first time I told my dad that
I was gonna go to film school and not
continue to play football he was
heartbroken you know he's really upset
he didn't want me to do it you know I
thought that was gonna be at the
thousand be what I was but um it there's
a short sightedness that comes with
playing with playing around sports man
like you know for so long man in the
shelf life on a career athletics is much
it's much more compressed in a career
another another thing is you know Saul
was you know I kind of thought about
this idea that you know you plan we
playing a football be fortunate enough
to keep playing professionally there
about telling you 30 you know you
considered a veteran you know I mean I
was very interested in getting and
getting into it into a space where you
know I was flipped you know me if you
touch my your 30 year old filmmaker
they're like are you a baby your eye
right here yeah and got so much more
it's so much more time to grow so much
more time to learn more about the crab
to continue to continue to stretch you
can do it into nine to you in a winter
you're like you know I'm saying so I was
with kind of attracted me to two
switches to switching career a college
coach once said you know 95 percent of
coaching college football is recruiting
you know if you able to get talented
players a lot of your work is done it's
done for yourself you know if the same
thing goes for directing when you cast
the right actors you know you find
talented actors that I thought that are
generally great people you know to me to
spend time with me being around a lot of
your work is done for yourself
I definitely got into this because
because um I believe in the power of
emotion you honor me and and I think
that film mechanism is an incredible way
to trigger empathy you know other people
in do telling stories you know to get
people to relate to characters that they
never they never met before and I think
that that that that is something that
lot that I always um want to be in tune
with not just as an artist but as a
human being
you know you know no put passion in the
things into my craft and put into motion
and it's my crap you know it's kinda
like this creature of two worlds you
know I want the private school you know
but I lived in some of some of them
somewhat more difficult neighborhoods in
the Bay Area so I didn't really fit in
anywhere except the football field I
really liked math and science and I was
I got a football scholarship to to a
liberal arts school called st. Mary's
College in the Bay Area and I went in
there and I was wanted to major in
chemistry you know I really liked
chemistry and I figured that if football
didn't work out I can always go to I was
going to med school become a become a
doctor and um that's cool because it was
a liberal arts school they made you take
these creative writing classes so I took
this creative writing class taught by
this professor who was also a novelist
and rosemary Graham and on the first day
of the first day of class we sit down
she just talks about how much she hates
football players oh yeah how football is
like the most barbaric ridiculous sport
should be outlawed and I'm like I'm like
in front of class like I think I want to
leave you know when I'm but but you know
we taught no yeah although we had a
little argument we agreed to disagree at
the time and she assigned us assignment
which was which is um you know tell us
about tell me about your most emotional
experience you've ever had in your life
I want you to write about it in prose
and it turning in and um I wrote about
mine I didn't think much about it I did
it honestly um if I you know if I would
have been thinking I probably didn't
written about when I wrote about you
know the name I turned it in and I was
in my dorm room hanging out with a bunch
of my football teammates and people from
my neighborhood I got a call from her
dorm phone and she's like um hey you
know what are you doing like her dorm
she's like I need to come down to my
office immediately
it's about your assignment so my Jesus
Christ step aside I'm like why do I
write upon today you know so I kick
everybody out of my dorm like I gotta go
in the night and I walk down to her
office and I'm just imagining like
you're not gonna overactive imagination
I'm imagining open up the door and it's
like the police and
and they hate on it in the NA I don't
know if college has a Dean of discipline
but my high school dislikes like Deena
discipline at the school and is higher
and I'm going for this world we're
meeting and I open up the door and I go
in and it's just her you know she's like
sit down so I go walk over and I and I
sit down across from I like I said now
Eugene right now and I'm she's like
looking at me you know those
uncomfortable silences she's like
looking at me I'm looking back okay you
know she says what you want to be when
you grow up I'm like man this is
terrible like this is me I you know so I
want to be a doctor you know and on
she's like why and like why come from if
he touched my you won't get doctor you
grow nobody asked you why I mean I like
great that's awesome yeah he did she she
she was she'll be like why and I was
like nobody ever asked my home I belong
for your doctor and I was like oh I'm
good I'm good at math and science I
figured you should use that if you get
at it in what better way to use them to
help people you know I figured doctors
can no can make money honestly and help
people while you donate be a good know
positive influence on the community you
know know what's wrong in it was wrong
me today and I she was like hmm this is
grandma my paper and she looked at
issues of all razor paper um and it was
really it was really visual you know
while I was reading it I felt like I was
there um she said that's actually
arguably rare than being good at math or
science um and you you should consider
being a writer you know you can you can
do the same things you're talking about
maybe even on a bigger level um you
should maybe even consider going
Hollywood writing screenplays
is what she said so I was completely
weirded out at that moment on my place
what did you think when she told her she
was crazy right I got I don't even know
what a screenplay was you know of me and
I remember looking at her and she had
all these books behind it like she's had
this wall of books and I remember being
I got a TD so I remember being like
insanely jealous because she has so many
books I don't like my like books you
know all I have any books you know um
and um I'll come back two heads but
which but she she um she said you know I
think you I think you should not think
about think about even writing
screenplays and um and I said so you
know I was taking she was craziest on my
way so I'm not in trouble and she's like
not why would you be why would you get
in trouble and I was I like cool so I
was like oh my god I get out of this
crazy book lady's office you know they
like saw my re like how are you all good
here she's like yeah that's fine but
talk to you about that you know just
think about it it's my cool song left
and I went back to my dorm room and my
dorm room was empty and I was like that
was the weirdest conversation I had my
life and um you know I had even know
what the screenplay was I never seen one
you know but uh but I remember thinking
about how much I like movies I always
liked movies I'm always like to read and
I started looking around my dorm room
and all I had was like rap posters I had
no books no I
I had no movies and I was like when I
like books I like movies like me maybe I
should start they got to start like
buying books and like buying movies so
then something I and I was thinking
about what she said about us pamphlet
like maybe I should check out what one
looks like so I thought I had 20 dollars
I'll hop them up to my car drove the
circus City and um I walked around a DVD
session and I found like this pulp
fiction I saw like proficient you know
and I picked it up it was a special
edition and it had um it had a cd-rom
with the screenplay
mm-hmm built into it so it was like 1799
somebody is perfect you know whitish
went back to the dorms
pop the cd-rom in and so my first
screenplay for it was like oh no they
was like um I know you remind me the
first time I stepped on the football
field and hit somebody you know I mean I
feel like I was at home yeah so so saw I
looked at it and I opened up Microsoft
Word and I thought the formatting was
kind of kind of weird so I started
trying to like hate the formatting in
Microsoft Word and I started to write
you know I started writing my first
screenplay
yeah that night and um and I stayed up
to relate in the morning I started to do
it everyday like I find myself I leave
in a waiting room like I gotta go back
and get on that you know get on that
script
I realized that I really really love to
do it and I professors like one of my
closest friends to this day
guys that a solid you got got it good
you got guys like great you know that's
the same thing like an athletic she's
gonna be um you know it's a difference
between a good player and a great player
you know a great player makes those
better around him you know great player
somebody who's incredibly has a
god-given talent but also a unnaturally
consistent work ethic you know what I
mean when those two things meet you ask
me you that's what you get that's when
you get when you get greatest no I mean
I always I had a back-up plan you know I
mean like like um it was never really a
back-up plan I got like um you know I
imagine in finance you could collect
like I liked it you know I mean but at
the same time I was doing I was always
doing screenwriting he's just the same
way when I was in film school I still
had my job you know back in the Bay Area
um for the doctor thing he just decided
not from yes yeah scratchy you it was
tough like I doing chemistry you're
playing football at the same time I was
like next impossible I don't know I
didn't want to be an undergrad for a
long time and on that on that track
because of football practicing because
of the labs not way that I would have
never graduated on time but it took me
like six or seven years you graduate I
got the idea for foot for doing this
movie like I showed you after the
incident itself happened um I was back
home in the Bay Area when Oscar was
Oscar was shot and you know I heard
about it around the same time everybody
else did you know now you get a call
from people who were riding a train and
how the barrier works is you know on San
Francisco is noise was where is where
everybody goes to see the fireworks in
New Year's Eve very white friend he's
bailing Haven going to Frisco tonight
we're gonna see the fireworks brush off
you know um and I go to you and you go
down to the to go to a park Adaro you
watching behind the Clocktower so so
anyway in the Bay Area is there and only
way to really get to the Bay Area is to
to catch it's the community I'd only way
to get to San Francisco to get to that
spot if you're saying is the catch the
BART you know so people come from all
different backgrounds and everybody's on
BART that night you know everybody's
coming back so when that incident
happened a lot of people heard about it
logical call it's a you know it's might
got shot like the BART station it can
get back home and train with delay and
and people send everyone to training and
I ended up hearing about it you know
that night I was actually working as a
bouncer at a rave in the city and I can
I got off and I heard about it in
another on that morning we found out
that he passed away and I had in
hospital and uh you know the barrier
kind of color was coming with her in an
upheaval um and shortly after that we
saw the tape you know so we saw we saw
had between you two been on the news and
um for me I was I was I was shocked I
was I was angered I was a frustrated
scared you know and when anything felt
filled with filled with the question as
a hardest get happy you know um and why
stuff like this continues to happen you
know how it could happen in the Bay Area
you know we're from we thought that this
you know the me thought it would pass
this kind of stuff um and fortunately
I'm a filmmaker you know I'm not and as
artists I think you know it's a very
natural for artists to get their their
fears and their hangers and frustrations
I'll do their art you know so so anytime
I see something that moves me you know I
think about it being being a movie or
putting it out you know I mean in that
format and um especially after I saw
what happened immediately afterwards and
how the case was was politicized you
know um and I thought that what if I was
able to make a film about this about
this character and maybe people who
wouldn't be able to come around
characters like this could see it you
know um and have insight on what it is
to be like to be someone like this and
have insight on why when these things
happened there a tragedy it's not just
something that you should you know throw
away as yesterday's news and you know
use something I said we should really
stop and think about what was the one
thing that Forest Whitaker said to you
as you were shooting it really stuck
with you there was something worse said
Sony's where is what I was people we he
doesn't talk a whole lot in everything
you said is really important and really
moving I think that I think there's no
one thing you told me was to talk to
always always always makes it make the
best decisions that you could make in
the moment you know honest and that's
all you can as all you can never do
I think he was referring to to take on
pressure that's around us around like
making a film based on a true story
making a film that that's said in an
area where it's a rare type of place
making the film you don't have a lot of
resources no making a film too short a
short schedule you just you just told me
don't make the advance the city that you
can has fate that's facing you and in
the move one I love I love movies man
and I'll watch them you know I watch
them incessantly you know uh-huh
and it does it inform your work or you
have to go to the theater no absolutely
definitely afford my work I think that
that um that's the best thing for a
filmmaker to do is to watch is to watch
movies you know um you know I love I
love doing and then when I see good
movies you reminds me of why why I'll do
this you know um there's nothing like
seeing it seeing a great movie and being
a filmmaker here so because it's
inspiring you know it's like it's like
wow man I did this is what this is what
um this is what the industry Don man is
capable of doing this is the fact that
it's capable of out of them want people
when it makes you want to get back and
get back into the lab and get you get to
work No thank you guys so much for
watching I made this video because Jaime
Martinez asked me to so if there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next leave it down in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I'd also love to know what did Ryan
say that had the biggest impact on you
what was the biggest lesson that you
learned from watching this video super
curious to find out please leave in
comments below I'm going to join in the
discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout out to rows 10 rows thank
you so much you're picking up a copy of
my book it really really really means a
lot to me so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon